hey guys welcome to nerding out the show
where we GameSpot nerds get together to
talk about the things that we like today
we're talking about fantastic beasts and
where to find them
I'm here with my buddy Tony and we saw
fantastic beasts it was fantastic would
you say I would say it was magical both
of those things do you have to be a
Harry Potter fan to like this movie you
do not you just need to like fun cool
exciting adventures yeah all those
things if you are a Harry Potter fan
you're gonna like it if you're not a
Harry Potter fan but you've been
interested in Harry Potter you'll
probably like this movie you like
Pokemon you'll like this movie yeah it's
got a lot of cool beasts and things like
that but you don't need to know too much
about the Harry Potter universe I think
it just enhances your experience if you
are very potter fan cuz there's a few
Easter eggs
let's talk about some things that we saw
that were that you might have missed so
obviously you heard Dumbledore his name
there's a couple of name drops if you
noticed um newts girl over across the
sea her last name is Lestrange
the most strange family is mentioned are
there any other Easter eggs that you
want to mention well there's a whole
thing about Grindelwald at first I was
like that name sounds familiar and then
we know that he plays a big role in
Dumbledore's story which is setting up
future films so that's setting that up
cuz I think we have four more films
after today yes yeah so also Newt has a
Hufflepuff scarf so that's a direct
shadow they mention Hogwarts and there's
also I pretty sure I saw a Deathly
Hallows yeah everything about it was
like yeah that is that makes sense I
think Harry Potter fans will like it it
doesn't it doesn't do it disservice to
anything else it is different you know
you don't have little kids running
around so there are some darker moments
but it has the same energy I think the
music helps you know it's it's a
different composer and I think each
movie has almost had like you know yeah
different composer for each one so it
does feel like a Harry Potter movie
even though it's in a different time
period different location different
characters so I think Harry Potter fans
will like it yes I think non Harry
Potter fans who've never read the books
or watch two movies I shouldn't enjoy it
I like this movie I'm a Harry Potter fan
but I really like this movie I also went
in with low expectations it's like you
said before a cash grab that's what I
thought it was I thought okay they just
want to feed into that Harry
Laure but I liked it yeah I thought it
was great it surprised me it was better
than I expected it to be and it's
already in like my top 10 movies of the
year yeah I'm ready for sequel at first
I was like five movies but now I'm like
yes please please let us know what you
thought of the movie in the comments
below and if you caught any Easter eggs
let us know about those too and for all
things nerding out stick with GameSpot
universe